this is a new show on Apple TV just
launched starring Hillary and Chelsea
Clinton take a listen Chelsea follows
rap music she has ever since she was a
little girl but I kind of came to
awareness of you with the cardi B WAP
I've always wanted to do a song with
cardio as soon as she sent me the song I
think I sent it back to her like the
next day and it was just so exciting the
men they seem so confident in what
they're saying and they don't have no
problem with talking about their
sexuality and how they gonna have sex
with you I can do that and it's gonna
Sound fire coming from a woman it's
great to see women be so kind of fierce
that is my life's Mission we need a
doctor at the daily wire I need
immediate medical attention for the
permanent cringe I don't know that I
have any hope of recovery uh wouldn't
you say it's so wonderful when women are
Fierce and I'm not the not the greatest
hip-hop Aficionado but by golly my
daughter Chelsea she's totally down with
the Jive I am embarrassed for them